[Musique]
c'est dans une ambiance conviviale que
s'est tenu ce week-end les halls factory
festival durant trois jours sur l'île
aumône à mantes la jolie une vingtaine
de concerts se sont succédé sur trois
scènes différentes
cet après midi là debout sur le zinc a
fait danser le public pendant une heure
c'est la première fois depuis deux ans
qu'on va jouer nos chansons devant un
public qu'on ne connaît pas et on
connaissait pas du tout ce festival et
on est très heureux de découvrir le
cadre est magnifique des gens sont hyper
sympa et en plus il fait beau pour ne
rien gâcher à la fête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
e
saxophone et clarinette font partie de
la fête puisque ce festival de musique
de mettre en valeur les instruments à
vent diversifiée et originale de mots
pour qualifier la programmation dès
cette année il va de la musique
classique en passant par le jazz la
world music il ya même des spectacles
enfants comme ce qui a actuellement
derrière moi donc il y en a vraiment
pour tous les coups on essaye d'attirer
le public le plus large possible sur 17
concerts 11 étaient gratuits les
spectateurs mais masquée mais avec le
pass sanitaires ou profiter de la
musique passe est merveilleux il fait
beau c'est très bien organisé
on attend aux patientes c'est calme
c'est familial en plus tout le monde en
très grand sourire quand on peut pas
porter de masque c'est coloré
ayant vraiment un choix de sun par
contre à ce super chouette sur trois
jours de festival environ 3000 visiteurs
étaient présents